idea what are your what are your
opinions on like waiting till marriage
sex before marriage yeah yeah yeah oh
that would definitely solve a lot of
problems
that was sold
sought out the um
std issue yeah that was over no that
would solve a lot of problems yeah no no
no i was saying this only because we're
currently in university that would solve
a lot of university problems because
because when people get
we have sex back in the day yeah sex
before marriage that used to be a very
good that's a golden state and you doubt
he was like set half of good people to
grow up and whatever now because people
are having casual sex and there's
nothing wrong with that but because
they're having to take so much like a
lot along with that there's a lot of
wrong with that but i'm saying like
as long as it's consented right what i'm
saying is like as long as a person can
sense it right you could that's fine
it's casual sex
right but then the casual sex can lead
to oh unexpected pregnancies yeah so it
causes a lot of problems